I don't think that we're maturing much
as a generation I mean look at me I'm a
grown man that's what that looks like in
2015
take a good look at a dolt head and then
look around because I'm not the only one
here tonight of legal drinking age
dressed for recess if a kickball game
broke out a lot of us would not need to
change clothes and I didn't put this 12
year old boy outfit on for the show
either I wear clothes like this every
day on my life I eat cereal for dinner I
play video games and if I see an
automatic door I may make a jedi motion
I like to read books too but I'm not one
of those people who thinks that any book
is automatically better than whatever
movie they make based on the book you
know a movie comes out or it's [ __ ] show
it's based in a book heaven goes out
with the book it's always so much better
not always books depend on me I have a
horrible visual imagination I can barely
draw the HBO has 57 artists with
master's degrees in making medieval
armor their version of Game of Thrones
is going to be way better than the piece
of crap production my brain put off with
the castle from he-man
I'm glad the game of Thrones is huge now
though so that regular people can see
the fantasy world that nerds like myself
have been living in since the 90s but
what's weird to me is that when nerds
create fantasy worlds and we are the
only people that do we create fantasy
worlds where we would die in minutes it
doesn't make sense it takes a long time
to write a book and a fantasy world can
be anything you want it to be why make
up a world where the good-looking strong
people win again why not make a world
where we come out on top
where it's like your knowledge of Bruce
Campbell trivia is impressive Lorde
stats but only he who eats the most
pretzel combos may sit on the beanbag
throw man I've always been a nerdy guy
but I never talked about it in my act
before but now that I do I take crap
from other comedians like oh you could
be the nerd comic now you're gonna jump
on the nerd bandwagon cuz it's cool now
cuz of Avengers I was like no I'm not
jumping on any nerd bandwagon I'm just
from a time when it was so shameful to
be a nerd that I'm only okay with
talking about it now 20 years later
if you wanted to play Dungeons and
Dragons when I was in high school you
needed three friends who could keep a
secret the first rule of Fight Club was
absolutely the first rule of pretend
wizard Fight Club
but now nerdy things are cool I was in
Chicago the city put out these chess
boards they're made of stone people play
chess in the park all day long I went
down there to see who is playing
expecting a bunch of pale nerdy clones
of myself it was all cool middle-aged
black guys every table was like watching
Samuel Jackson play Forrest Whitaker
and I didn't know why and then I went to
New York and they had chess boards too
but they had two kinds of people playing
there were black guys but then there
were Jewish guys from Russia and then I
was like okay now maybe I get it you
know both groups have had a long history
of oppression maybe to them chess looks
a lot like how life works you start all
the way in the back an entire country
stands against you every level of
society from the king to the bishop to
the army they want you to advance no
further
you only get one move at a time and if
you mess up even once you die and white
Christian people heard that and we're
like that's not how life works I know
the bishop he loves me life works like
my favorite game Monopoly you start out
with a ton of money you drive around
blowing a ton [ __ ] and if you mess
up you use your get-out-of-jail-free
card
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please